大家好 哇塞 今天台灣股市不得了了
處置股新規定
哲哲剛好講在前面
我們看一下今天台灣股市三大重點
今天台灣股市寬拉千點又放A 怎麼了
如果一個男人昨天告訴你 今天台灣股市會放A 你相信嗎
第二個
證交所放寬處置規定大力多 如果又一個男人
呼籲
哇 這個處置規定啊
不太好啦
苦民所苦
結果又預告在前面了
證交所犯官這規定
對中小型個股是不是一個大利多
這個又有個男人預告在前面
是不是又是我
不好意思就是我
第三個
Plantier
這就跟我沒關係好不好
營收報徵93%
AI股還有的漲嗎
這三大重點
我還有明天獨家告訴你
明天台股要怎麼走
今天三大重點
我一次講過
還有很多標股
環球經驗又漲停了
又預告在前面了
台股今天早盘开低走高
由低到高狂拉超过千点
但五盘又灌下来翻黑
最后小跌了25点
收在43,360点
这么震荡该怎么办
而投资涨的股票也全面喷出啦
投资涨的选美小姐
环球金股价90度急拉
直喷唱涨停
我爱美元的中美金也大涨超过半根涨停
精彩和国具也持续上涨中
而昨晚有一件开心的大事
就是主管机关真的听到投资长的心声啦
因为证交所宣布大幅缩短处置期间
并加快分盘挫合频率
你想知道现在最新的处置规定会如何影响台股吗
你还没上车
手上还没有标股吗
接下来就交给我们经济日报选股冠军
單記188%的記錄保持著
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
投資長好
大家好
我剛去看完綜藝又回來了
因為昨天挑個正胸舞
結果才過正太胸
開玩笑的
昨天點閱率還不錯
但我要抱怨一下
等一下再抱怨
這不是重點
來啦 我們先來看
台灣股市
今天中小型个股涨
你告诉我为什么涨
你很简单嘛
3532台胜科以后开始
不好意思再涨上去也没关系
处置规定
不管是什么五个交易日
十个交易日
以后好像都变成五个交易日
另外是单充的
我不要讲太复杂
我怕你听不懂
第二个
以前要20分钟或10分钟或5分钟
交易一次像变成两分钟了
以后变两分钟了
哪個分析師告訴你
說啊這樣不行 股票會跌啦 你告訴我
哪個分析像我這樣子
你告訴我嗎
哪個老師
有像我們這樣子有一絲絲的影響力
當然其實我告訴大家
我其實我通常不太去管主管機關的
做法啦
為什麼你知道嗎
因為我很尊重主管機關啦
我名不與官鬥啦
只是我這一次苦民所苦
哇
這個規定我其實我當分析師喔
但是20年來我特別有感覺
這一次特別有問題
以前你們有遇過什麼叫聯發科被處置
你有聽過嗎
這真的沒聽過
沒有遇過啊
這一次又莫名其妙
股票跌跌了
我就說這種中小營個股跌法是股災事
是金融海嘯事的啊
所以我就說你用力買股票
你們不理我啊
啊
每個人在幫我數
我一億的新來幣
一天就賺一千萬
我說你們不要幫我數鈔票
我氣死了
還有人說我一億的新來幣
買0050指揮員生死於不顧
我說我最討厭氣這句話
我說我寧可不買
我說如果我要的話
我寧可去買環球金
我可以買的話
你們看到環球金又暫停啊
環球金又暫停喔
而且禮拜五是這樣子喔
禮拜五是這樣拉起來以後對不對
不好意思
我還說什麼我說會大
大展特展我還
有沒有 我大展展展
我叫一堆人去追那個展庭
是不是
是
那時候好像國際股市大噴發
有沒有印象中
我還說去追展庭
哇 折折去追
有沒有
哇 很多人說
折折去展庭是不好
結果看到現在都對
環球金
哇 很多人說買很高
拜託我有從500元買
也有600元 也有700元
最高到1000元
所以你現在買你還是划算喔
跟某些人比較起來
你看
我才真正苦民所苦
我要是一一心才必買環球金
我現在現賺就賺2000多萬了
你看
所以
歡迎你進什麼了
台聖課拉馬
我不是處置的規定不行嗎
你們看一下
這最新的規定
問大家最新規定
你看一下
台股觀景病規定
松板經濟工商
直報頭版都是這個新聞啦
請問你哪個分析師最在乎你的感受
沒有你看到很多老頭顧分析師
唉唷
我暫停 我暫停
上禮拜叫做
妖怪獻星記啊
上禮拜還能跟你天天暫停的
你要參加那是你的事情
好不好
我也不要去講是誰
你看我苦名所苦
我先丟了一
我也苦啊
怕被你們笑
我不怕賠錢
我怕被你們笑啊
是不是你知道嗎
是
所以今天台灣50跌
我根本不在乎
因為我會員現在很多股票拉起來
我反而最開心
你告訴我哪個分析師
能知道這個是重要的事情
一直跟你講關琴幣不行
不就是我嗎
我雖然很激動
來
你們看關琴幣
來放鬆以後怎麼樣
你看我的預告
會起雞皮疙瘩
真的會起雞皮疙瘩
這個就是影響今天中小型股股
所以台灣股市今天跌
我連跌都預告到
我今天預告會跌
可是中小型個股因為這個關係大載
看一下
看一下 很恐怖啦
7月30號
還禮拜五的時候
來
7月30號
那時候國巨你看
現在國巨多少錢
直接看
2327國巨
是不是尾盤頭拉對不對
對
7月30號這邊456元有沒有看到
有
跌在這邊456元 有看到嗎
7月30號國際跌停版
456元
到今天566元
多了210元有沒有看到
有
多說說
最近多少
說說說
多了110元有沒有看到
很誇張吧
長了20幾%有沒有看到
沒錯吧
456到566沒錯吧
沒錯
好不好
大家應該記得566洗髮金嗎
不記得
你不要跟我講話
因為你很年輕
說記得
記得
嗯沒錯
好
466 早上566
你看466元
怎麼預告的
你看國際可以買不到
國際可以買
這是456元哦
放大放大
456元
沒錯吧
跌停板哦
鎖死2000多張哦
456元哦
好
再拉遠
看一下
我懇求主管機關
懇求哦
證交所懇求哦
如果蔡良分寄師還不知道這是證交所管的喔
懇求喔
我很客氣喔
我很客氣
我不是
我不會去嗆主管機關
我很客氣
來
國際那天是456嘛對不對
現在566嘛
566洗法金
來
做生意我很公道
我告訴你這個股票現在就是可以買
國際也可以買
可是我也懇求主管機關
證交所
真的因為我不是分寄師
我不要太慫
慫動人家
把那個儲置改一改
像一堆股票被儲置
聽懂不懂
是
你下跌的時候你反正儲置要打開
不是下跌還被儲置
股票最怕是流動性問題
最怕是流動性問題有沒有知道
有
政交所准進生流動性問題喔
會解決流動性問題喔
剛才不是這樣講嗎
頭版新聞不是這樣講嗎
來
你儲置是人家追漲停
讓人家清醒一點
下跌你還儲置
20分鐘交易一次誰想買
聽到我的喔
制度遲早要改喔
20分鐘交易一次喔
現在改成2分鐘交易一次喔
這個制度真的遲早要改
這支柱真的吃好改
好 我也不多說了
你看 這個支柱真的吃好改
我是預言家耶
你們不要看我跳什麼正胸舞
嘿嘿嘿
不要跳那個東西那不重點啦
靠腦袋
你們不要一直基於我肉體
應該也不是基於我的錢吧
基於我的腦袋
你們應該渴望我的腦袋
哪個分析師跟你預告這個
連政教所這東西我就跟你預告了
我剛好已經個股蛋拉起來嘛
莫名其妙
就這麼簡單
你知道嗎 我昨天跳這個舞喔
跳到腰痠背痛
點擊還沒有增加
一群直男都不願意看我節目
投資長他們一定是嫉妒你啦
是嫉妒嗎
不是嫉妒啦 應該是有些是直男啦
不要這樣講
他們直男有時候頒不歪
你知道嗎
你知道以前不是有個故事嗎
不是有個故事嗎
哇 爸爸說
召集兄弟
說怎麼把直男搬歪
一根筷子 搬得歪
兩根筷子 搬得歪
十個筷子 就搬不彎了
搬不彎
來 我試一下
哎呀 這還是搬彎了
可能因為我有100萬個粉絲啊
直男啦 講等笑話
直男很難搬彎
看到直男跳舞不舒服
不過不論是直男還是斑彎的
還是美女
我通通愛你們
只要你們是我粉絲
好不好
OK嗎
好啦人笑話了
財經綜藝節目大家喜歡就好
可是你看財經綜藝節目喔
哪個人像我在預告
再來看一次還有一個預告喔
禮拜一是不是
是不是禮拜天是不是台灣股市崩盤
跌一千多點沒錯吧
我還預告嘛
跌1077點有沒有印象
有沒有印象
有印象吧
有
有印象因為你沒來加班
你在桃園啦
不好意思叫你來 是我沒叫你來
有沒有印象
有在家裡有看嘛對不對
有
我是不是說台灣股市會翻紅
說禮拜一會翻紅對不對
你看喔
這都預告在前面 很恐怖啦
來來來
給你看一下
預告在前面
來來 看一下看一下
看喔
等一下 我要把CC字幕打開
我們直播版
那個也有CC字幕喔
我們字幕板是
字幕直接簽上去的
直播版要打開CC字幕
這個CC在這邊
有個字幕C
CC字幕
我說禮拜一會翻紅喔
我這是禮拜六來錄影的
我說禮拜一翻紅
這太高
我認為有70%喔
明天跌的幅度會再-300點
後天跌就是禮拜六錄影 禮拜一啊
以內
甚至有機會翻紅
記起來我說的 好不好
為什麼有機會翻紅 我敢預告
我禮拜六 台灣股市 台紫期跌一千多點
我說翻紅 厲不厲害
厲害
昨天 我說今天會翻黑
可是小型國會長
我昨天看到處置規定 我知道小型國會長
是不是 來 我們看看翻黑
來
很恐怖喔
那你看禮拜一是不是翻紅
是
沒錯吧
大盤是翻紅
沒錯
是不是
大盤翻紅對不對
今天台灣股市是下跌的喔
看一下
下跌我看我怎麼預告
更恐怖喔
下跌的
來喔
我跟你講韓國股市最後是什麼
等一下喔
我洗一洗
來喔
我昨天說今天會跌喔不過台灣股市最後跌5.13%所以台灣股市今天算很強因為台灣股市是紅的所以明天跌我覺得很正常我覺得明天跌很正常
因為韓國股市比想像中
台灣股市如果預期的強
可是韓國股市比我想像中弱
如果明天韓國...
韓國股市明天在跌
就是今天跌啦
今天韓國股市在跌
我給你到前面好不好
好啦 以後你們看不出來
我這個V字領的衣服了
搬不彎這些人 我搬筷子
沒有啦 開玩笑
好 這開玩笑
你告訴我三大預測
四大預測啦
一億跌破三萬九千點
我十幾大預測
跌破三萬四萬點
我是買一億台灣五十
隔一天以後我是馬上賺一千萬
沒錯
我會尋賞兩億喔
你說我造假尋賞兩億喔
你去看永鋒金9A 9J
永鋒板新的就知道啦
這怎麼造假
所以為了一億幫我保守秘密啊
是不是他可以拿我一億耶
如果造假的話
第一個一億賺一千萬
第二個我說你要買
你不要幫我數鈔票還笑我說股票跌
我叫你去買什麼國具
買跌停的國具
買跌停的環球金
能買幾張就買幾張
用力買
用你的生命去燃燒他命就一條啊
怕什麼
褲檔裡面還有錢啊
我連我的粉絲裡面高檔百分之無三
褲檔裡面還有錢
抽屜裡面還有錢
我怎麼拿出來
最傻就把錢放在抽屜
最傻把錢放在銀行
你以為我跟你開玩笑
不是砸這些財新週刑節目的直彈
你記起來而已啊
你告訴我啦
真的不要只是基於我肉體
你們不是渣男渣女啊
大跌的時候還想到我肉體
長的時候都沒有跌月率
跌的時候才有跌月率
媽咧
不要這樣子
你們不是啊
你們是渣男渣女嗎
然後每次跌的時候才找我
難過
如果一個男生都需要你的時候還找你
你會受不了
完全不行
完全不行對不對
你看我被你在柔令你在20年
每次都大跌的時候還理我
大展的時候
跌一流下滑
大跌的時候都需要我
講一講話哭出來
真的不會哭啦
你看這個預測
買1億台灣50就算了
國際的預測
環球金的預測
一些
我說我現在要買跌月生的股票
我問你一件事啦
你看台積電這幾天有動嗎
沒有啊
在一天二十二兩天
我是不是說台積電
我是一大堆預測喔
你們不要看我
別人下我颱風天
我笑他人看不穿喔
欸這不是
有人說這是電影
這不是電影的那個
這是舒適的詩吧
我記得這不是電影情節的
有些人說我抄那個周星馳的電影
不是不是
好扯遠的
別人下我颱風天
我笑他人看不穿啦
來
你看一下
在這邊
是舒適還談博弧
對不起我忘記了
反正這是詩詞
不是周星馳創造的
來
我是說過上禮拜漲到2400多元
對不對
對
我說離高檔怎麼樣
我說離高檔很近
漲不上去有沒有講
有
我說這個時候換什麼
換環球金換美金換什麼都好
不是 我就在講
換跌月生的股票
我是不是告訴你 換股行動
有國際的人也怎麼樣 你換不下去
是不是 價差行動
我還知道你被套牢了
被套牢了你是要價差行動
你賺三百元 賺三百元 賺三百元
因為國際我跟你講
接下來漲到七八百元的時候會因為有壓力
我是有預告
然後我說現在台積電就有些有壓力
因為台積電離高檔太近了
有沒有講
有
你看現在漲的都是那些跌生的股票
你為什麼台積電為什麼那些
你那邊跌比較少的股票
現在是一種悲哀耶
你懂不懂
你要把跌少的股票換在跌多的股票
有沒有講 有講
有沒有講禮拜一每個人都預測跌1000點
我說台灣股市會漲 有沒有講
有啊 我反乎從那個精神
從時光屋裡面走出來的男人啊
有沒有講今天會跌 有沒有講 有
有沒有講處置規定要改變
改變要做阿琴個股會噴出去 有沒有講 有
你看我第一次看完節目你就胡扯
怎麼可能這麼厲害的男人
怎麼可能
10個筷子會斑彎的男人
你們怎麼那麼厲害
這個不重要
好啦
這呢
一告在前面啊 各位
一告在前面啊
未接什麼東西
每個人在罵主動型ETF的時候
我反而給他支持 我給他愛
真的 真的 好不好
這跟大家講好不好
來看一下
我看一下
我是真的有點難過
難過是趕快來加入Handee好不好
趕快加入Handee
我跟大家講
這個反彈99專案你要不要參加隨便
因為我不差生意
我生意很好
我會很多
明天就截止
自己參考好不好
反彈99專案
等一下我要教你一個簡單數學
不會讓你覺得很難
我們先看一下跟大家互動
今天都沒看大家互動了好不好
來
小黃剛才他們有講什麼嗎
他們覺得哪一段比較好笑
不知道
看一下
不要激動 我們都聽你
你很紅
小心血壓
我每次都請莉莉提醒我等一下血壓
都還可以啊
大概就剛好是12080
先跳我再考慮會員
再跳一次是不是
是確定嗎
哲哲不確定會員
要不要參加隨便你們
對 要不要參加隨便你們
可是不是那種很拽的文字
講起來OK
這只要幫我搬彎的
好不好
這桌子哪一家牌子做的
撐得住不錯
哪該這麼多請問看好有趣
有趣要準啊
哪個分析是管理什麼處置股生死啊
我一直講苦民所苦啊
我一億我根本不在乎啊
你有沒有發現到
我那一天我買一億
隔天台灣股市台灣只有攢上去
但禮拜三買
禮拜三不是破3.9萬嗎 對不對
是
禮拜三這邊不是破3.9萬嗎對不對
我這邊買對不對
對
隔天其實台灣50有拉起來一點點喔
因為我買很低
拉起來一點點我其實不開心耶
你知道我不開心嗎
因為很多人說我在賺錢啊
會員在賠錢
我聽得超不開心的
這幾天台灣50在跌
我反而很開心
為什麼
因為你要買可以買
第二個因為我的環球金拉起來
金彩拉起來
環球金漲停一直漲停
國巨一直漲停
然後今天又再拉起來
然後我也說過
我說有很多股票
我說2377維新
有機會先創新高
有沒有講
看起來要創新高了
有
我哪件事情最近預測
哪邊有問題
我是全台灣最敢預告的男人呢
也是最敢跳正胸五男人啊
好啦 以後不跳了
這不是我傳承
小時候比較愛運動
像有記得斷章取舞的話
我這小時候我喜歡讀書
讀書
小時候都在讀書
打電動 運動也有
運動也有好不好
我記者拜託
現在有個新聞你知道嗎
挖著著踩雷
說我Gia 19根跌停板害人家
講清楚
是有人抱怨我
Gia我在高檔的時候就賣掉了
不能那個會員你告訴我Gia
哪裡有那你得到19根跌停板
我印象中沒有
是Gia過一段時間19根跌停板
那個人才說他看我節目
我感到很內疚
可是理論上應該不是我害他
因為他沒有每天看我節目
不能怪我啊
是
我也不知道他是真粉絲還是假粉絲
可是我很注重風險
可是網路上變成說
哇 哲哲踩雷
所以注重風險
他講一半而已
懂嗎
聽懂嗎
就像網路上都有哲哲的
很奇怪的言論
哲哲這頭髮是假髮
真髮啦 假髮
每天三個禮拜剃頭一次
你是不知道
沒有關係
有人說哲哲台灣50賣掉了
沒有沒有
你沒有邏輯想好不好
我怎麼可能賣台灣50
我領先說 我領先說
我賺了1000萬就賣台灣50對不對
是不是
是
我們假設喔 我4萬連買
我不是隔天就4萬3嗎
我賺1000萬就賣台灣50喔
你再低估我自三了
我絕對不會這個時間賣的
我買1億 我敢買出1億來
馬上賺1000萬
我今天就賣掉
如果股票下去
一般人會覺得我是股神
對不對
會不會罵我啊
你自己賣掉 你有沒有叫我賣掉
沒有喔
我幹嘛賣
對
所以我不會只賺1000萬就走啊
那怎麼知道
好 我
我一億賺1000萬馬上暫停滿嘛
好 我賣掉以後沒有跌 反而漲
會員不會罵我 但你們會嚇我啊
我幹嘛做一件事情
漲也不對 跌也不對的事情
所以我絕對不可能
只賺1000萬就走啊
至少要到5萬點
大家皆大歡喜的時候我在考慮嘛
我原則是6萬點啊
是
那懂我腦袋邏輯啊
我為什麼要這時候賣
我賣的機率是0啊
懂嗎? understand
我說沒錯吧
跌下去了一定有會員罵我
你跌下去了
你自己這個高檔給我賺一千萬就走了
我會員為什麼不全部出掉
那除非我會員要一起全部出掉
我幹嘛這個時候出掉
我說第一檔咧
展上去你又笑我
郭忠祐少賺好多
我又不是白癡
看這個笑嗎
你不要以為我肌肉大就覺得我是傻
OK嗎
不要再結這一段
愛你們啦
好啦
來
先跟大家講人紅是非多
只有六萬點賣的選擇
真的啦有沒有看到
如果極竭玩不會玩
想知道怎麼可能會這個時候走掉
一堆人不看哲的直播在那邊造謠
記者有時候斷端取緣不要說照搖
我也愛那些記者啦
我也不想得知記者
三週檢法看起來真的
00981A買台紙期怎麼看
台紙期怎麼看
我沒有什麼想法
買台紙期沒什麼想法
他可能覺得台灣股市跌太兇
想要反彈吧
就是他可能
00981A買台紙期
你有沒有想過某種方面
我這不是錯沒有
某種方面他也認同我買台灣50
來
我說沒錯吧
對耶
有沒有 所以00981A
其實越來越多
你會覺得正名太好看我節目
欸 我說叫他
我說我支持00981的國劇
有沒有
隔天國劇就
00981A他就買了
別人都賣他就買了
沒有錯吧
沒錯
第二個00981買台紫棋
某種版面不是買台灣50嗎
來 我告訴你喔
買大盤對不對
第一個
最好的選擇
沒有槓桿
沒有槓桿的對不對
買台灣50
對不對
沒錯吧
沒錯
買台灣50嘛對不對
就民型的沒有槓桿
兩倍的
對不對
買什麼
買那個
那個台灣50真二
啊槓桿更多呢買誰
買台紙棋啊
是不是
沒錯吧
沒錯
像陳寅老師喔這這你買台灣50我買台灣50真二我說喔
我說這樣算我吃我豆腐嗎不會我剛剛很熟啦大家很好
陳老師很認真
所以我講一件事喔
00981買台子旗
你覺得跟我們沒關係
我是不好意思講而已
你覺得我沒有影響力嗎
他們在做什麼大概知道啦
好不好
只是沒關係
可是我在講一件事喔
其實很多同心經理人們看我的節目啦
好不好
我說愛你們啦
我就是好不好
我只說可能英雄左鍵電筒
我就是中心一點
英雄左鍵電筒
你
他買00981A他買台子旗
代表什麼意思
第一個嘛
你看好台股大展
覺得這邊四萬點是低檔
你第一個
你比較保守的人就買台灣50
就我啊
因為我有教育的意義啊
主動型ETF是比賽績小
誰管理什麼教育的意義啊
是
對不對 這沒錯吧
你再激動一點
你再貪心一點就買那個
正二
你50正二啊
台灣50正二
再不然就是再更感動一點
就是買台子企業
這懂我的邏輯嗎
某種方面應該有參考我們啦
應該有啦
或者英雄所接連頭
懂我的邏輯嗎
好不好
OK流量要拼過館長我們先看肌肉可不可以贏他應該是不行喔開玩笑好啦 不要這樣子來我什麼都不想買架
想看你跳舞
不要這樣子啦
好
怎麼啦 總理好人說
你用下半身頂喔
敢這樣講
好 沒關係啦
來
技術分析在牛市下值高對不對
國際跟黃斑店可以進展
國際還可以喔 好不好
機體也可以啦
黃斑店我們看一下
黃斑店本來就應該拉
黃斑店
黃斑店最猛 三根斬停板
黃斑店昨天應該也是斬停
對 昨天斬停 三根
黃斑店我沒注意到它
233到117
喔 太 五十拍
哎 早上應該買黃斑店
有太多股票你知道嗎
你看是不是疊越增展越多
是不是
哎呀
納克很厲害啊
納克中施度打鼓很厲害
根本就沒有什麼回答
記憶體還會拉啦
其實我的群點實在沒夠力
不夠力啊
三點多
嘖嘖不夠力
三點多真的不夠力啊
我有講過嗎
兩千雲散群點是買點喔
好我先跟你講喔
我講的任何一句話
來本資要請給我參考
好不好
基本上你
我的東西喔
你把它分散投資
然後現金
All in我覺得也不錯
現金然後分散投資
用閒錢分散投資
我覺得 我認為 尤其是我會員
績效 中產期待間
不會太差啦 好不好 OK嗎
我們是分析師
我不懂有些人為什麼要去看那些網路上的
連執照都沒有的
考不上的
然後說蓋世英雄 你相信嗎
然後給你收錢 你相信嗎
唉
我們也不要去批評特地的誰啦
我只講一個現象
你就考分析師嘛
你不想考分析師很簡單嘛
你不想被監督嘛
我說沒錯吧
沒錯
你不想被監督啊
你想做股票啊
不就這樣子
最好是你推薦股票你可以買啊
這個新造不宣
那我們要特別批評誰
我覺得我沒差
我少賺一點沒差
我已經再給你看我實力了
我剛剛期貨啦
一天漲一天跌啦
拉上去啦
是不是
跌一天點拉起來啦
然後還跟你講說台積電
你要換成什麼
中小型個股換成跌升的
然後出自股規定要改
這些東西你告訴我誰能預告
比那種暫停太熏調
每天都暫停
大跌的時候也每天暫停
你也相信 我沒辦法啦
我沒有辦法 我沒有辦法
只能救一個是一個好不好
好不好 OK嗎
骨骸無牙
我先看一下我們的簡訊
我喝個水好不好
看一下
都吃在簡訊又回來了
環環金73%
環環金1000元左右
我還要買加碼
我告訴你
所以我還是可以買
我是告訴你喔
我還是可以買
中美金我記得200元附近我有買
所以我跟你講這邊沒有什麼不好
這邊沒什麼不好
OK
中美金我覺得成本比較低的不是175
我覺得思想你寫錯了
所以中美金我可能還會再買
好不好
我這都不用怕啦
OK嗎
世界先進都可以買啦
年發科你看賺了多少
100多%
國際賺100%
國際是我名言
我叫他漲就漲
我叫他跌啊
他不敢漲
造谍啊
我叫他反弹就弹
我叫他暂停就暂停
請問你
你們這邊誰有意見
有沒有意見
沒有
沒有意見
沒有意見沒什麼好講
好不好
無意通過
來
來喔
來看一下環球經
念一下 念一下
好
8月4號星期二
恭喜6488環球經
股價表現不錯
成功鎖上漲停
我們買進到現在最高
已經大賺73%
我持續看好它
手上持股報好報勞
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
我真的滿開心的
黃永慶掌精品
黃永慶那疊了
因為黃永慶我講滿大力的
是
我跟你講
到時候黃永慶才是真正的
被動雲件3.0
矽晶圓
我想就知道
陳舟自成也需要矽晶圓
這個不需要
是不是
連記憶體也需要矽晶圓
你懂不懂
你這不需要
唉
我跟你講到時候他缺 記憶體越缺
那為什麼現在不缺
很簡單
我問你啊
記憶體如果說擴產馬上就擴產
現在還會缺貨嗎
我可以講很堅實的數字
我不需要 我不屑喔
有些人說哇
從研究員那邊背資料
來講得很厲害啊
哇 不論是記憶體或PCB啊
哇
什麼DDR5
LP
DDR5
X什麼的
講得很專業啊
HBM啊
這個電流啊
你都是用背的而已
你知道嗎
一般工程師也可以背
我講最簡單的 我只在乎邏輯
這邏輯很簡單
為什麼記憶體需要矽晶圓
為什麼現在環球晶的財報還沒有很漂亮
你看到最新的財報還虧錢的
那是因為股價認定的問題
那為什麼記憶體最需要最擅油的
記憶體很缺嘛
記憶體現在最需要擅油的環球晶
為什麼環球晶沒有噴
很簡單 因為記憶體很缺
記憶體可以馬上擴散嗎
記憶體如果可以馬上就擴產
然後擴產兩倍三倍
那記憶體就不會那麼缺啦
股價就不會長那麼多啦
就是因為需求急增嘛
供給趕不上去嘛
這不就這樣子嗎
沒錯
股價會這樣長就一樣
東西會這樣長就需求急增嘛
供給趕不上去嘛
沒辦法擴產
沒辦法這麼快速擴產
所以答案來了
什麼時候會需要矽機源甚至缺貨
等到記憶體越來越不缺
或是基體開始擴產成功的時候
如果基體擴增兩倍
基體是不是
基體擴增兩倍了
一定要擴增兩倍以上的啦
很多東西一定要擴增兩倍以上的
因為需求不止兩倍
基體擴增兩倍
那細菁員要不要增加兩倍
理論上要啊
然後為什麼現在沒有
就是因為現在還沒擴產成功嘛
等到擴產成功後
你環球性都飛到2000元了啦
2000嗎
2000元是出估而已啦
我跟你講
本資料僅供參考
好不好
還是記得一些
藍雅科40幾塊的時候
我跳到哲哲善車舞
什麼哲哲什麼
那個叫我台車嗎
你記不記得台車
你還忘記了 小漢子
大漲紅圖嗎
大漲紅圖
哲哲推薦什麼
藍雅科什麼
對對對 忘記了
是不是
那時候40幾塊
50幾塊
我買
好像漲到70幾塊
又得到40幾塊
被一堆人罵
你看現在轉眼間要500塊了
星星也是一樣
70幾塊
121塊 70幾塊
還被人家慫恿
哇 被一些分析師 被誰慫恿
哇 這是不是害人啊
結果主管證交所還我清白
哇 我還第一次知道是要簽結
簽結是兩個檢察官告訴我
只是一點嫌疑都沒有
要兩個檢察官喔
因為你看一下 因為
要告我告的時候 70塊變成 700塊
結果告我同業身體有變好嗎
業績變差 身體還沒變好
早知如此合併單初
我還是要幫他祈福一下
剛好指的例子告訴我一件事情
不好意思
這時候可以砸一千萬兩千萬在消防車裡面
也可以砸好幾百萬好幾千萬
找律師辯護我自己甚至提告
我不在乎
人在坐天在看
我沒有的事情你不要誤賴我
這就是我個性
如果有事情我該承認就承認
我跟大家講
我絕對不會去故意害會員的
這我不屑做的事情
我已經在證明我能力了
我不當分析師可能賺更多
拜託你們好不好
扯遠的
有時候講這個事有點生氣
來
恭喜2327國劇連
真的是人工是非多
好不好
要看我跳那個舞
也是經歷過很多
那個好不好
很多酸甜苦辣啦
不過我都正面思考
就像一樣嘛
看電影如果主角都很順利也很無聊
是不是
都一定要經歷過啊
一堆挫折
恭喜2327股價連兩天斬停後
今天繼續散場
兩根斬停有沒有看到
我們趁上週跌停勇敢進場
馬上就獲利大撞
我指示告他
雙層獲利細胞
請問你觀世這國具
你到底誰買的比我們漂亮
你告訴我
You tell me
Tell me
真的沒有啦
精彩那時候跌停是跌停是不是
是不是
今天這禮拜五展停
禮拜一展今天又拉起來了
精彩幫我唸一下
唸一下
來
真的很精彩
8月4號星期二
恭喜3374精彩
股價連兩天漲停後
今天也繼續上漲
我們買進到現在最高
已經大賺66%
我持續看好它
手上持股獲利續報
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
OK 賺大錢啦
這跟大家講
所以
只是預告在前面
好不好 我真的很認真
但我們標題要改效
跟依依講一下
處置股新規定
好不好 感人處置新規定
標股無敵
這無敵不代表真的無敵
而是有利於 好不好
新規定
跟事業講一下
這有點過重
可是過重剛好適合股票
你在講的時候
我已經飛到外太空去了
你知道 飛太遠
是
可是股票真的很適合我
我會跳來跳去跳來跳去
你知道嗎
而且我覺得很恐怖
有時候講的
很多人你知道嗎
就是網路上開始講我的生平故事
就是他們很厲害
他們都上網去找
然後其實我大概一年講不到
一次我自己的事情
比如講我是過動額
我也不知道我是過動額
因為誰
你告訴你
你讀書
你怎麼知道你是過動額
人家叫你專心
你怎麼叫什麼要專心
什麼叫不專心
你根本不知道
而且從老大大我成績都不錯
所以我怎麼知道
什麼叫專心
我根本不知道
我有一閱讀障礙
扯遠了
這個跟大家講
所以這蠻厲害的
大家很多記者現在
哇好像很了解我
是真的
所以過動額有好處
做股票
這樣過動不錯
扯遠了啦
精彩啦
對 我們那個期貨我們賺多少點
忘記了
期貨好像也是賺兩三千點的
好不好
期貨是在四萬點做的嘛
現在期貨多少點呢
看一下
四萬零七點
我們四萬零七點
期貨
期貨今天賺133嗎
所以我們期貨還是賺三千三百五十點
我們是在四萬零七點做的
賺三千三百多點
那者者為什麼要沒走
不是不是不是賺三千多點而已
不要開玩笑
我前日有賠耶好不好
我賺更多
來 股票也是一樣
真的精彩很厲害好不好
好不好
微信要拉起來
我在前面有件事
來
來來來
你們不要覺得股票漲很多
我給你最後的邏輯來看一下
像幾分了
我們給你最後的邏輯
像很多股票是
漲兩根斬停盤
對不對
對
我們教你一個簡單數學
很簡單
不要聽到數學就走掉
好不好
背後
來
我們簡單數學
-40加20%
變多少
負40加20的人
那你說
那應該是負20啊
喔不是喔
不是嗎
負40加20等於負28
為什麼
這是好事啊
100元對不對
是
100元跌到40%是不是變60元
60元再漲20%變得大
72元有沒有錯吧
60元再漲20%變72元
不是回到80元沒錯吧
沒錯
是不是
就是100元跌40%變60元對不對
60元再漲20%
現在很多股票漲20%啦
兩根漲停盤
很多股票都兩根漲停盤
很多股票現在都
這幾天都兩根漲停盤以上啦
只會變72元
不是回到80元
-40再加20
不是等於-20
是等於-28
所以代表什麼
你
它只是變72元
不是變80元
你還是買很低
這也是喔
100元跌40%
是不是變60元
對
60元再漲20%變72元
所以減40%加20%
不是回到80元 只回到72元
你這邊為什麼不做
我就說啦
環球金我一直加碼
舊會員有些買很低
所以這一波再殺下來舊會員沒抱怨
頂多半天說這時候
賺100%你還不走 你好貪心喔
可是他們其實不會大抱怨可是有些人買了1000元的環球金比較不好意思買了200元的裝美金比較不好意思所以你今天參加會員我問你一件事情你很多還買了低檔
你比方買要低啊
是不是
現在確定底部你還不買
你看到大盤是這樣子喔
大盤是這樣走對不對
這大盤對不對
沒錯吧
上跪植樹這樣走
我是大戶
我是中植物
我榮心大躍啊
對呀
以後兩分鐘處置一次
我敢尻下去
我敢買下去啦
你懂不懂意思
懂
看20分鐘交易一次很恐怖耶
我昨天還前天講的
只剩一小時
一
12點半的時候
只剩一小時的時候
只能交易三次啊
三到四次要幹嘛
你怎麼把握
拉起來
壓力大得要死
兩分鐘交易一次不止啊
你懂不懂
一小時的交易可以30次啊
是不是
而且以後不會什麼處置
什麼10天啊什麼的
兩個禮拜
兩個禮拜很恐怖耶
緊多就一禮拜
那也沒差啊
一禮拜然後兩分鐘交易式
很好買啦
我是覺得連下跌都不要儲置了
股票如果下跌就不要儲置
不要因為下跌而儲置它
是
我在講第二個預告
我覺得這個有機會再改
不要因為下跌
股票跌就最好的懲罰
你還下跌儲置它幹嘛
連儲置都不該儲置
但這個已經改了非常多流動性的問題
好不好
所以你看頭版新聞
都直接講頭版新聞
有分析
很多人都看我節目
我們都不用看金金光山時報了
真的好不好
是不是頭版新聞都講了
處置規定鬆版了
有沒有看到
處置時間
錯的時間都怎麼樣
變短了
總之你真的要注意啊
不要像到時候我講的
現在43000你覺得可惜對不對
47000你可憐啦
500000覺得可悲啊
為什麼你空手啊
空手到
人生都要空手
空手的來 空手的走
享受他嘛
人生就命一條 怕什麼
有沒有覺得很後悔
再給你一次三萬九你會買嗎
No no no
如果你現在不會買再一次三萬九
你還是不會買 為什麼
因為你就是永遠嫌貴那一群人
我告訴你 如果
我告訴你 就技術分析你
十個技術分析高手
九個有說現在買比三萬九買
划算
而且你說沒有錯喔
我只能變長頸路
脖子出來
就技術分析來講喔
現在買喔
你看像上規則現在買
現在買
你現在追高
不是現在買比這邊買還漂亮
這邊買叫Modi
這只有我超級高手的高手
一般高手在這邊覺得這邊買最漂亮
因為確定底部成立了
而且新規定
懂嗎
有處置的新規定
真的你相信我講的話
所以你現在都不敢買
你三萬九也不敢買 為什麼
你現在不敢買不就是怎麼樣
你怕買貴嘛
是不是 你怕買貴嘛
那三萬九你還是怕買貴啊
你現在不買原因不就是怕它下跌嗎
那三萬九再來一次你還是怕它下跌啊
你給騙自己啦
所以再來一次三萬九你還是不會買的
只說我一買我一買
買一張
你褲襠裡面的錢只夠你買一張
我比你自己還喬得起你
我比你自己還喬得起你 你命就有錢
真的啦 好不好
不要這樣子
不要每一次看到哲哲
幾分啊
不要每次大跌的時候才看到哲哲
是不是
大展的時候看到哲哲看兇正午
兇正午
哎呦我是直男
我不想看哲哲兇正午
沒興趣啊轉台
你轉台有什麼用
大跌的時候還不是要轉過來
你轉台有什麼用還不是要轉過來
看我的節目什麼時候買0050
什麼時候買0050
那就一直看就好了嘛
是不是
告訴你這邊買比較划算
你相信我講的話好不好
這邊買真的比較划算
再給你們第二個想法
來
這都很簡單數學啦不要覺得很難啦
百貨公司週年慶對不對
85則變9則你買買
現在85折變9折嘛 對不對
因為很多股票
折況沒那麼多對不對
1萬元85折是8500對不對
台灣公司包包嘛 對不對
香水也可以
你現在變9000的變貴啦
白鴻跟中間慶變9折怎麼辦
可是以後可能變了1萬塊啊
是不是
我就要買85折 我要買39000的台灣股市
現在就有430000你要不要買啦
你買不到450幾塊的
國具啦 你要不要買660元的國具啦
好 你不買沒關係
今年不買嘛 你等明年週年慶嘛
可是明年會變2萬塊啊
蛤
有可能啊
台積電前幾年
2022年的時候
2022年喔
380元啦
2022年啊
380元啊
4年前
No no no no 現在2026嘛對不對
3年多錢而已啊
3年多錢
380元
我跟你講喔
保安公司的東西不會漲那麼快喔
股票會喔 為什麼
你們就不懂股票最終的意義
股票就是你買股票
你投資這家公司的所有員工
沒錯吧
沒錯
讓他幫你賺錢
台積電的公司的員工
他包含什麼夜音計畫的24小時
幫你服務的那些人
幫你工作人員都是幫你打工
你是台積電員工
可是當你成為股東的時候
你也是台積電的老闆
那這些賺來的EPS
獲利
部分會發給員工
先發給員工以後才變獲利
然後再發給股東以後
會有禁止
會留在公司
這些留在禁止裡面的
這些留在公司裡面的禁止
就是這些錢
賺來EPS留在公司的錢
會慢慢增加
你禁止
假設
我問你一件事
你有可能
假設台積電禁止
假設最簡單的
跟現在不符
1000億變2000億
你股價有辦法回到以前
變1000億的時候嗎
你的價值1000億變2000億
你現金就1000億變2000億了
你股價能回到那時候嗎
回不去了
又不是傻瓜
市場有一群力道啊
所以股價中長期就是我一直晚上
只要好的公司
這樣能不懂
懂我邏輯吧
我今天告訴你很多投資觀念
不要看只會凶正午
不要看只會把你們搬歪
是不是
不要這樣看喔
好不好
所以你去想看你要找什麼意思
好 第二個
今天這個稍微打廣告
沒有打廣告
那70元沒在賺什麼錢
那LINE貼圖 有LINE貼圖好不好
大家想要的話自己可以下載好不好
好不好 哲哲名言貼圖啦好不好
投資產名言貼圖
不要用另外一個啦
另外一個那個
哲哲不算授權給另外一個那個
這個比較好
是郭忠祐投資產名言貼圖
就這個
我知道你還有錢嗎
有這個貼圖
還有什麼
來啦
火山事噴出
一切一切預告到前面
Line貼圖
因為有很多人說怎麼出Line貼圖
我早就出過了好不好
很多新粉絲
我們到時候出第二趴啦
這是第二趴更好笑啦
好不好
比如說
你們到底是要我肉體還是愛我的錢
這樣
上載你也不敢買
下跌30趴你也不敢買
退出股市算了
類似這種
大家喜歡的梗圖
我就把它做個
做個名言貼圖
好不好
比較
這是第一趴
這是第一趴的那個名言貼圖
第二趴的
你看 直求對解
這就是天分 不好意思有沒有看到
老天爺送給我的禮物有沒有看到
股價下跌老天爺送給我的禮物
好不好 好啦
這不是重點啦
這不是這個
70塊沒有要給你做生意啦
真的勉強要做生意的
說是受生意的這個
反彈究章案
1剩幾分 現在幾分
470差不多結束
小孩今天跳很激動
我以為好像50幾分一樣
好結束了結束了好不好
世界共環球經紀
今天法說有沒有什麼重點
我們看一下
這要看一下
世界環球晶
這我重要的股票
查一下
納科財報噴出去了
這有看到嗎
整個太紅的Trade上面
很多詐騙分享給你
詐騙的很狠你知道嗎
所以我就超級討厭臉書跟
IG看起來是不是一樣
他們同工公司啊
可是我不確定他們管理是不是一樣
詐騙的現在第一件事
就開始檢舉我的IG跟Trade
他把我檢舉完以後
他們就變成
他們就變成就是
就是沒有正統的嘛
這也太壞了
他變成合法的你知道嗎
是
非法先把合法檢舉下來
你就沒有合法可以看
你沒有合法可以看
你就只能看他的
我臉書這樣被檢舉下來啦
所以我不用臉書啦
我被檢舉十幾次啊
IG跟脆現在是這個東西
S178 178
沒關係他把我檢舉
你們詐騙團進去把我檢舉下來
檢舉下來我就是把這一欄都把它刪掉
我說以後不用IG跟脆
我直接講我不用IG跟脆
你們連看都不用看
那些詐騙團連用我都不能用我
我沒差
反正最聰明的
我用YouTube也有個好
我也沒差
我用TG也沒差
我沒差
你知道嗎
他把我毀掉是最傻
我直接把IG跟Trade都不要用了
就是只要在IG跟Trade
是我的官方名義的
那就假的
也可以
目前不是
目前是以這個為主
IG跟Trade是SE78
不是什麼SE78
SE78
多一個少一個都不行
他們很厲害
納科技
看一下
字節
7月份字節
你不要給我營收 直接給我EPS就好
都沒有轉台 好不好
他們說是沒台公司 我知道 我知道 我知道
大家不敢買 對
只得空點9萬多怎麼看
不是9萬多口啦
環球金Q2 EPS 7.9元
算不差啊
你就只得24元40倍本益比
你不能這樣講啊 如果昨年增加
是要給我看一下Q1的EPS
跟去年Q2的EPS
好不好
聽紅綠燈一男一女在討論者者
你知道嗎 他們吵架啦
女的說 哇 只能跳真兇舞很好看
男的說 有什麼好看的
可能在吵這個吧
不要吵 不要為我吵
我兩個都愛你們好不好
開玩笑的 我怎麼知道你們在講什麼
夜盤噴
明天我不預告明天的台股啦好不好
好啦 沒有什麼問題喔
所有環球巾世界還沒有
世界麻綠一針有沒有講
世界有沒有什麼重點
我們看一下
有啦 環球金四連法說啦
有沒有
世界先進啊
因為已經
它好像已經滿載了
平均銷售單價
人家計增2到4%啦
不錯喔
滿載了還可以經營源出貨量
計增1到3%
等於溫和的持平
至少可以抵消大家覺得
台積電賣它好像不行了
對不對
所以世界經濟明天有機會漲
世界經濟明天有機會漲
不論對我或我做
整整一切一切
在預告前面
反彈92專案
今天精彩
今天什麼
環球金展停
國際兩個展停再展停
金產兩個展停再拉
還有維新準備算新高
你要不要反彈92專案
歡迎來一價錢
080668185
或加我LINE
私信我
不論對我或錯
預告前面
你不選台灣最好的分析師
同樣的價錢
選別人
何必呢
不是不行
你要不要選擇
要選
就選擇最好的
最好的
你們家有沒有
歡迎來電視頻
08068085
或是家我帶你私訊
我說這這
我要參加會員
這這
會費怎麼算
我捷徑我所來幫你
賺大錢
掰掰
先獨立判斷、審慎評估並自負投資風險
谢谢大家